- [Instructor] So right
here, we have a reaction
where you can take some
carbon monoxide gas
and some hydrogen gas,
and when they react,
you're gonna produce methanol,
and this is actually pretty interesting.
Methanol has many applications.
One of them it's actually race car fuel.
But we're gonna do is
study how much methanol
we can produce if we have a certain amount
of carbon monoxide and molecular hydrogen.
So let's say, we have 356
grams of carbon monoxide
and 65.0 grams of molecular hydrogen.
Pause this video, and based on this,
figure out how many grams
of methanol will we produce?
Well, a good place to start
is by converting these numbers
of carbon monoxide, this
amount of carbon monoxide,
and molecular hydrogen into moles.
And so to do that, we can take out
a periodic table of elements
and the molar mass of carbon monoxide,
you can look at the molar
masses of carbon and oxygen
and add them together.
So 12.01 plus 16, that is going
to be 28.01 grams per mole.
And if we want to convert to moles,
we're gonna have to multiply
this times moles per gram.
And so for every one mole, we have,
we just figured it out 28.01 grams.
And this is going to
be approximately equal
to 356 divided by 28.01
is equal to, let's see,
and we have three significant
figures here and four here.
So I'll round to 12.7 moles,
approximately 12.7 moles.
And then we could do the same thing
for the molecular hydrogen.
And here we're going, for every one mole,
how many grams or what's our molar mass
of our molecular hydrogen?
Well, each hydrogen atom
is 1.008 grams per mole,
but each molecule of hydrogen
has two hydrogens in it,
so it's gonna be two times six, so 2.016.
2.016 grams per mole or one
mole for every 2.016 grams.
And so this is going to
be approximately equal to,
get the calculator out again,
65 divided by 2.016 is equal is to that.
And we have three significant figures,
four significant figures,
so if I round to three,
it's approximately 32.2
moles, so 32.2 moles.
And so the first thing to think about is,
in our reaction for every
one mole of carbon monoxide,
we use two moles of molecular hydrogen,
and then that produces one mole
of methanol right over here.
And so however much
carbon monoxide we have
in terms of moles, we need
twice as much hydrogen.
And so we see here a molecular hydrogen.
And so two times 12.7 is going to be 25.4.
So we actually have more than
enough molecular hydrogen.
And so we are going to use 25.4
moles of molecular hydrogen.
How did I do that?
Well, it's gonna be twice the number
of moles of carbon monoxide,
twice this number right over
here is this right over here.
And we can immediately see
how much we're gonna have leftover.
We're going to have leftover,
leftover 32.2 minus 25.4 is 6.8,
6.8 moles of molecular hydrogen.
And how many moles of
methanol we're gonna produce?
Well, the same number of moles
of carbon monoxide that we're using up.
It's a one-to-one ratio.
So we're going to produce
12.7 moles of methanol.
And so let me write that a year.
So if I have 12.7 mole of methanol, CH3OH,
how do I convert this to grams?
Well, I have to multiply
this times a certain number
of grams per mole so that
we can cancel out the moles
or essentially the molar mass of methanol,
and to figure out the
molar mass of methanol,
we'll get our calculator out again.
So we have four hydrogens here.
So four times 1.008 is going to be that.
And then to that,
we're going to add the
molar mass of carbon
'cause we have one carbon plus 12.01,
and then plus one oxygen
in that methanol molecule
is equal to that.
And let's see, we will
round to the hundreds place
because our oxygen and carbon molar mass
is only went to the hundreds
place here, so 32.04,
32.04 grams per mole.
So we have 12.7 moles
times 32.04 grams per mole
will tell us that we are going to produce
that much methanol.
And let's see, we have three
significant figures, four,
so I'll round to three.
So approximately 407 grams of methanol,
407 grams of CH3OH.
Now the next question is,
what's the mass of hydrogen
that we have leftover?
Well, we just have to
convert our moles of hydrogen
that we have leftover to grams,
6.8 moles of molecular hydrogen times,
the molar mass here in grams per mole
is just gonna be the reciprocal
of this right over here,
so times 2.016,
2.016 is going to give
us this right over here.
And if we were rounding to
two significant figures,
which I have right over here,
that is going to give us
approximately 14 grams,
approximately 14 grams
of molecular hydrogen
is leftover, leftover.
So we used a good bit of it.
We used about 51 grams and
we have 14 grams leftover
and it was carbon monoxide
that was actually the
limiting reactant here.